it's game on the political collision
course over the supreme court is going
forward
president trump set to announce his
nominee on saturday
and senate republicans say they have the
numbers to hold a vote
the partisan infighting is just getting
started here's just a small sample of
what will likely be
the nastiest confirmation fight we have
ever seen
leader mcconnell has defiled the senate
like no one in this generation none of
them
assert this majority would be breaking
any senate rule by holding this vote
it's just that our democratic friends
worry they might not like the outcome
what senator mcconnell is putting the
senate through now is so destructive
after kavanaugh everything changed with
me they're not going to intimidate me
mitch mcconnell or anybody else
and that back and forth is just the
beginning democrats making
all kinds of threats to try to stop
republicans
that includes nancy pelosi doubling down
on potentially impeaching
the president what is your power to do
this i get the election but you have you
can get
up more you can speak out more you can
do more
impeachments things like that do you
have enough power
well we can impeach him every day of the
week for anything he does in fact for
200 people dying well because
look the american people want to know
what we're doing that affects
them directly and president trump says
bring it on they want to impeach me
again
if i nominate somebody as i'm
constitutionally obligated to do
to serve on the supreme court of the
united states
go ahead if i want them i want them to
do that
i want them to say that so republicans
were holding their breath the last 48
hours and then
gardner alexander and then today dana
mitt romney i mean i think everything's
falling into place it looks like yeah
you kind of kind of love mitch mcconnell
who has the votes
and yet is so calm and doesn't you know
dance in the end zone
or is that what you say sure dan's in
the end he's just calm right so he's
like yeah i got the votes and we'll have
a vote and
it's very calm and meanwhile you have uh
schumer
and durbin and other democrats outside
with a poster board
you know the old-fashioned poster board
trying to say mcconnell is wrong on
process
um and mcconnell wins that argument so i
think that was a huge game changer
um i do think that there will be a vote
this year i actually think it could be
before the election
um because in some ways why wait right
and also
um i think when it comes to the senate
races that are on the line
and that is on the line um it helps
democrats and a couple but probably
helps republicans in
more than it hurts for hurts them
probably four seats for
republicans it probably helps them to
have this fight greg did you know that
mitch mcconnell has defiled
the senate by holding this vote what a
verb but a
democrat would know what defiling
is i mean look at their cities dana
happy halloween
um so i looked at the list of all the
nominees
and they're all women right and we all
have to accept that
it's like they're all there's gonna be
no guy and that's not sexist right
it's just assumed that it's going to be
all women but there's one woman that is
not on the list
hello judge jeanine right right
i mean if you're going to fill that seat
exactly and
i want her to feel i want her to be
nominated because i have the title for
her next book which would be
courtrooms criminals and crooks
my time is a supreme court justice in
donald trump's america
yes yes okay so to the impeachment thing
you know what impeachment is for uh the
democrats and the media
it's the genie lamp that they keep
rubbing
like assuming that it's the impeachment
is actually going to come out of the
lamp
but those lamps only exist in cartoons
like
aladdin i'm pretty sure the republicans
should continue to employ
the gfy strategy which is go
f yourself you guys have been you guys
have been ray
guthfell you guys have been smearing us
for five years calling us names
you keep threatening us why is why are
you gonna be nicer to us if we don't do
this
we expect that language out of dana not
you the bottom line is if you got the
ball
you gotta score that's all you gotta do
uh
judge jeanine let's go to juan uh juan
what is there they're still in shock i
know i know you're virgin ears
not only that but we go back to the file
because i i think
i was glad that he didn't tell us what
that means that's all i'm saying
can the democrats do anything
procedurally
at all to slow down or stop what it
looks like is coming in the senate i
don't see it
jesse i think that what we learned today
is that the
republicans are going to stack the
supreme court they're going to have a
six to three
majority and i don't think there's much
they can do about it in the short run
trump will use this the big question is
how does it affect the presidential race
right because i think right now
it looks like as everyone said mcconnell
has the votes and he intends to
use his power it's brutish but he's
going to do it i think it
really does hurt the institution but so
be it that's the way it is in a
totally polarized political system at
the moment
but i say it's how does it affect the
presidential race and right now i think
the president is using it to distract
from his primary liability which is his
failure to deal with coronavirus
so you know today we learned what 200
000 plus
have died from coronavirus in this
country
uh and i think right now he doesn't have
you know
he doesn't have any answers uh and i
think
you know the added vote on the court
given that there's an obamacare
case coming up right at the week after
the election
so i think pre-existing conditions and
the like
right there on the ballot for democrats
to see
i think you also have trump last night
saying virtually nobody this is what he
said in the speech
virtually nobody is affected by
coronavirus he said because
it's you know young people are not going
to get sick healthy people are not going
to we know he's wrong i think he knows
he's wrong he told bob woodward he's
wrong
but he says this stuff you know to me
that's why
you know i think this former pence aide
this young woman who came out and said
you know what i can't do it i quit and
then she said trump
said oh yeah i'm glad to have
coronavirus because it means i don't
have to shake hands
i think people should pay attention no
she's not very i don't know
and you paraphrased them completely and
correctly as for the 200 000 that was a
prediction that was even made by experts
after you flattened the curve if you
hadn't planned the curve no if you
flattened the curve
it was up to between one to two million
and by the way
stat replacing uh or filling a vacancy
isn't stacking the court right we know
what stacking the court really is
it's adding more judges okay no stacking
is when you don't let democrats
legitimately nominate
a candidate every time every time a
democrat nominates
the president nominated garland the
senate just didn't no they wouldn't hear
they wouldn't get both there's a
difference
six the
get in here juan say it's a distraction
that he's talking about this vacancy on
the court
from covid19 i see it as him fulfilling
his constitutional obligation to
nominate someone to fill that vacancy
what do you say you know who
controls the power of the purse the
congress and nancy pelosi so where the
hell is she
in passing a new stimulus bill
there's a compromise bipartisan
compromise one and a half trillion
dollars
you're going to get what 450 extra per
week in unemployment benefits
they're 12 more than 12 and a half
million of people just collecting state
unemployment benefits extra 1200
checks half a trillion dollars to the
states
the blue states the leaders of which
don't know how to do
math nancy pelosi is on the
talking about impeachment where is she
on this
she left town and she left unemployed
americans
millions of them in the lurch she left
town rather than passing even a
small a skinny bill and i've been
thinking about this
why are the democrats huffing and
puffing
so much and caterwauling about the
hypocrisy like pulling their
shirt collars because they got
themselves into this this is
pure misdirected outrage and
self-loathing
it started with harry reid what seven
years ago got rid of the filibuster
then donald j trump beat hillary clinton
he's going to have three supreme court
justices appointed
in his first term potentially and then
you have the the senate is in a better
position because of the four democratic
senators who voted nay on
justice kavanaugh they lost their seats
so mitch mcconnell's in a better place
so you know what i'd be hating myself
too
if i was a democrat because here we are
the self-loathing democrats
more on that